eu já pensei em me matar e não foi uma
nem duas vezes eu sentava no parapeito
da janela do sétimo andar do prédio onde
morava
todos os dias eu era adolescente eu
estava enfrentando um quadro de síndrome
do pânico e depressão
um mal que atinge mais de 300 milhões de
pessoas no mundo e que também é o mal
que mais tiranos saudáveis dos
brasileiros
eu sou neta de psiquiatra
eu sou filha de psicanalista mas ninguém
conseguia me tirar do quarto pra mim não
existia mais ou fora do quarto
existe apenas um canto no qual me
afundava cada vez mais um dia minha mãe
bateu na porta e reúne todas as minhas
forças para abrir uma festa e foi para
aquela festa que ela me disse uma frase
que eu nunca mais esquecer filha
se você não quisesse ajudar ninguém mais
vai te ajudar
eu queria me ajudar eu sabia que eu
queria me ajudar mas eu não conseguia
como é que eu podia querer me ajudar e
queria me matar mesmo tempo quantas
vozes moravam dentro da minha cabeça uma
me dizer que tinha saída ea outra só
conseguia olhar para o parapeito da
janela
quem era eu no meio dessas vozes
eu era um corpo que doía era uma
tremenda dor de cabeça eu era um oco por
dentro mas ao perceber que eu não sabia
direito quem eu era
eu me dei conta também de que eu podia
ser diferente de que a vida podia ser
diferente
e aí eu me agarrei aquela esperança como
um náufrago se agarra um colete salva
vidas numa noite de tempestade no dia
seguinte minha mãe conseguiu levar o
psiquiatra era ano de vestibular
eu não podia mais faltar à escola então
eu comecei a tomar remédio
só que naquela época os remédios para
depressão não eram tão sofisticados
condição hoje eu engordei 10 quilos em
duas semanas
fiquei arrasada a sensação que eu tinha
era de que se meu pai fosse atropelado
ali no outro lado da rua
eu nem consegui gritar tamanha apatia
que eu sentia
mas aos poucos a gente foi ajustando a
medicação e devagarzinho o ânimo começou
a reaparecer
e aí além de o psiquiatra eu comecei
também a fazer terapia e eu me lembro
que ela me deu três dicas
a primeira dica é para que eu cuidasse
da minha da minha alimentação como quem
cuida da alimentação de um bebê ela
falou assim mas presta muita atenção se
você quer realmente comer aquilo se você
precisa comer aquilo e se você puder
preparar pra você o que você vai comer
melhor ainda
a segunda dica que ela me deu foi para
eu tentar dormir direito e no começo eu
tive uma medicação que me ajuda a fazer
isso ea terceira dica foi pra eu voltar
a praticar atividade física e aos poucos
eu fui melhorando e fui voltando a ser a
mãe que eu sempre fui
as minhas amigas me convidavam para
jantar pra comer pizza para tomar chope
pra enfiar o pé na jaca na balada e eu
recusava e elas achavam que era porque
eu tinha muita força de vontade de
continuar com a dieta
mas na verdade eu abria mão das
companhias que eu tanto amava
por medo
eu tinha muito medo de que qualquer
deslize me levasse de volta
para o parapeito da janela era um
monstro que rondava que estava o tempo
todo à espreita eu não queria mais
encontrar com a depressão
então eu mantinha a minha disciplina na
atividade física na minha alimentação e
tentando dormir direito
isso muito antes eu tenho que falar
sobre saúde na televisão
e funcionou funcionou até que eu fiquei
grávida ea gravidez foi pra mim uma
licença pra sentir
eu me sentia distante do mundo eu me
senti a lula
eu me sentia feia eu me sentia por todos
os medos concentrados num único porte a
minha dose diária de angústia era
assistir a minha substituta na televisão
de dentro da minha própria casa eu
achava que ela era mais bonita mais
inteligente que ela tinha uma conexão
melhor com meu parceiro de apresentação
eu achava que ninguém mais precisava de
mim e eu não tinha mais ninguém para
bater à minha porta porque a minha mãe
morreu quando eu tinha 20 anos vítima de
um avc
mas foi aí que me lembrei de uma porta
que está sempre aberta a meditação
eu comecei a acreditar quando eu tinha
12 anos eu era amiga do dono de um sebo
que ficava na esquina da minha casa e eu
ia lá passava as tardes com ele pra
gente conversar sobre machado de assis
fernando pessoa josé saramago manoel de
barros
até que um dia ele olhou pra mim e falou
assim
mari se é pra você esse livro é a sua
cara
o livro se chamava visualização criativa
e tinha uma mandala na capa
eu tinha 12 anos não tinha a menor idéia
de criar uma mandala
eu não tinha a menor idéia do que era a
visualização criativa mas eu tinha muita
curiosidade para saber por que que o
dono do sebo achava que aquele livro era
minha cara então eu corri pra cá
e comecei a ler o livro e comecei a
fazer os exercícios que o livro propunha
e um deles era assim imagina uma bolha
dourada na sua cabeça depois na sua
testa a sua garganta no seu coração um
pouquinho acima do umbigo um pouquinho
abaixo até chegar na região pélvica
eu coloquei um cd da eni no meu micro
system e comecei a fazer o exercício só
me dei conta de que aquele exercício
tinha durado mais tempo do que eu tinha
planejado quando o cd acabou eu tinha
ido com um lugar mágico cheio de luzes
douradas lilases violetas verdes azuis
um lugar que me parecia mais real do que
a realidade
eu lembro de ter pensado assim gente
será que é isso que o pessoal chama de
entrar em alfa
eu tinha meditado por acaso sem saber
que eu estava meditando e acho que por
isso que foi tão fácil da primeira vez e
é claro que no dia seguinte eu quis
repetir o exercício eu quis voltar para
aquele lugar mágico mas não funcionou
e aí com a prática eu fui entendendo que
a meditação profunda não tem nada a ver
com essa nossa vontade de controlar o
mundo
a meditação profunda ela requer entrega
e não controle
a meditação da aquilo que eu chamo não
de big data da saúde mas decor teta ela
te dá acesso aos dados do seu coração
cocó de conectar o de observar seus
pensamentos suas sensações seus
sentimentos suas emoções
depois que se conectar ou observou bem o
r de respirar com tudo o que está ali
a respiração é a nossa única função
automática que a gente consegue
controlar é tão bom quando a gente
consegue controlar conectar observar
respirar para depois escutar eu fui
aprendendo a reconhecer os meus finais
quem reconhece placas de trânsito na rua
eu fui aprendendo a cuidar de mim sem
precisar que ninguém bater se na porta
porque como eu disse a maternidade me
deu liberdade para sentir e além de tudo
que eu já falei eu também senti o maior
amor do mundo e eu senti que eu queria
cuidar de mim porque eu curtia muito
cuidado em outra pessoa
e aí as meditações começaram a mudar um
pouco porque assim como existem inúmeras
dietas
existem centenas e centenas de formas de
meditação lá atrás eu editava para
conseguir o que eu queria eu tinha uma
meta fazer uma visualização e conseguia
criar a minha realidade a visualização
criativa pressupõe isso que você é capaz
de criar sua própria realidade
mas depois que eu virei mãe a minha
meditação mudou um pouco
eu comecei a meditar para abrir meu
coração que eu comecei a meditar para
ter mais bondade
eu comecei a meditar pra sentir mais
gentileza para vivenciar a gratidão
porque hoje a ciência já sabe que a
meditação pode sim funcionar como um
grande filtro porque ela altera
circuitos cerebrais e deixa a gente mais
otimista
a gente passa a ver a vida com outros
olhos com os olhos que também autora da
visualização criativa via a gente passa
a vida de uma maneira linda e exuberante
abundantes como ela realmente é
a ciência também já sabe que a meditação
ela ajuda a controlar a pressão arterial
e os batimentos cardíacos fatores de
risco para enfarte e para um avc como
que matou minha mãe
a ciência também já sabe que a meditação
ela não é legal para quem está na crise
da depressão pode até piorar mas a crise
já passou
ela funciona tanto quanto remédio pra
evitar as recaídas e o que eu sei
e à minha prática diária de meditação
não é por um momento que eu estou
meditando mas é pra todos os momentos da
minha vida momento a momento o que eu
sei é que em se tratando de saúde
a única coisa que você não pode deixar
de fazer por você é aquilo que só você
pode fazer por você e é por isso que eu
continuo cuidando da minha alimentação
cuidando da minha atividade física do
meu sono e meditando todos os dias
obrigado
[Aplausos]